we are back and you know our next guest
for soulful songs like Jar of Hearts in
a thousand years and for her lullabi
music on her album songs for Carmela and
songs for Rosie she has a new single out
as part of her holiday album songs for
Christmas now performing Christmas dream
give it up for Christina
[Applause]
Perry
gingerbread for you and for me candy
cane mountains and sugary trees Sligh
rides through clouds laughing out loud
dancing with snowflakes round and
round I can't wait for your first
Christmas
Day watching the joy in your eyes I've
been waiting for for all of my
life sing you to sleep
and your Christmas
tree your Christmas
[Music]
tree
caroling and popcorn on string castles
of cookies and rivers of cream Meo
kisses and Santa Claus wishes stockings
full of your favorite
things I can't
wait for your first Christmas
Day watching the joy in your
eyes I've been waiting for all of my
life sing you to sleep and
your Christmas
[Music]
dream your Christmas
dream I can't wait for your first
Christmas
Day watching the joy in your eyes I've
been waiting for all of my
life I sing you to sleep
into your Christmas
[Music]
tream all right one more time everybody
let's here for Christina Perry pick up
holiday out right now we'll be right
back with what I'm
liking
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home